obviously one of the greatest the
greatest times in american history like
the space race going to the moon yeah we
had a national mission we all came
together we all believed in it and now
we have lost social cohesion
the left has some kind of weird social
cohesion but it's not rooted in i don't
know about that i mean
you know the way i wouldn't call that
cohesion
maybe maybe that's fair maybe it's fair
but they are connected somehow you know
what i mean like they follow they follow
it's it's a it's a swarm of bats
i think a lot of it is super i don't
think it's like
i think you like strike the shepherd and
the sheeple scatter sort of thing
on the left yeah
i don't know
i went to a black lives matter protest
last year in brooklyn
and i held up a sign from that had a
kendrick lamar quote that's on it a
fatal attraction is common and what we
have common is pain
to try to spark a conversation about how
in many cases the same
uh
fears traumas what have you that
communities are experiencing also exist
within the police officers that are
policing those communities so but that
didn't actually spark any conversation
but what i did notice was that there was
no actual spiritual underpinning
uh
people knew what they
didn't want they didn't know what they
wanted
and
um and so
that
was not
i mean yes i i met people who have
become my friends for sure but that was
not for example in comparison to the
civil rights movement it's something
that created actual sustainable
community so i'm i'm curious
i would question the stability and
sustainability of
some of the movements today i question
whether or not they actually know what
they don't want
well that's fair so one of one of the
things that uh uh i talk about a bit is
they claim to know what they don't want
i don't say that right when they claim
sometimes claim to know what the
solutions are abolish the police or
defund the police but they clearly don't
want that because then when the police
show up and arrest their political
opponents they cheer for it sure
one of the things i think we see
that i bring up often the root of the
culture war in my opinion or one of them
was how algorithms were feeding people
shock content for money
and so what happened is you're let's say
you're 10 years old in in 20 in 2009
and you get on facebook even though
they're not supposed to because it's you
know for 13 year olds or not but you
know kids are on it anyway yeah all of a
sudden you see in your facebook feed a
police brutality video a black man being
beaten by a cop okay
there were there were websites that were
making millions of dollars posting
nothing but police brutality videos
because it's shocking and it gets clicks
outrage yeah so now you're 10 you see
these videos and it's all and you click
on it so facebook says let's give you
more
then 10 years later these videos have
become dominant because it made so much
money for people that now there's a
there's a there's someone who's voting
who genuinely believes the world is
nothing but police hunting down black
people
their whole world view is built upon
this fictional reality of these extreme
instances that are actually exceedingly
rare they're bad and we should stop them
no doubt yeah but exceedingly rare then
they show up at a protest and quite
literally verbatim they say police are
hunting us down yeah and if you try and
tell them like hey
that's not true
they get angry they get violent
and then how do you calm someone down
whose whole life has been built into
this broken world view well that's not
the space first of all to try and
console someone down for sure but i
don't mean like go to a protest and walk
up to somebody who's angry and screaming
and say hey you're wrong i mean like
even even my friends
where it's like i've been i was hanging
out their house and i would say things
like this they'd be like you're wrong
you don't understand and i can't believe
you would say this stuff like i did i
thought you i can't believe you're a
racist and i'm like dude why are you
getting angry you know what i mean i'm
not mad i'm just these things are
reality well i think it's i don't know
you might be having a overly cerebral
response to an emotional
express
form of expression that is correct uh
and i don't think you will that doesn't
match
those two will never match you need an
emotional expression to respond to an
emotional expression but here's the
right balance of cerebral and emotional
here's the challenge i face with this uh
so when i used to do uh nonprofit
fundraising canvassing stuff like that
okay uh
oh hands down i knew absolutely the
emotional pitch was always better than
the factual pitch
when i was working for a homeless
shelter i didn't go up to people and say
did you know that 17 children per day
are found blah blah blah and if we work
together the average annual budget of
the homeless shelter will come nobody
cares but if i said yo
we had a kid last night
his parents both died in a fire and now
he's sleeping in the ditch
i want you to i want you to think about
that for two seconds like what is that
could you imagine not having parents and
then they'd be like oh my geez like what
do i gotta do yeah the emotional was
always better but you know what
i don't like it because it's different
because it's disingenuous why is it
disingenuous so
when when you're honest with someone
you
can be nice to them you can be
compassionate empathize
and say i am going to lead you to water
and i'm going to be nice about it
but if you've got someone who's like
fervently locked in a world view over a
decade of believing that cops are
hunting down black people
and you try to say to them
you know listen
i understand these things are horrible i
would like to help you in stopping them
from happening i would also like to
consider that
you know these these instances
are exceedingly rare and though we
definitely should focus on fighting them
we should try to do it from a
level-headed perspective and they'd be
like no you're wrong you're not you're
wrong i see the videos all the time i go
on reddit it's nothing but these videos
you're trying to you're trying to
downplay
but why should your reaction be
dependent upon theirs
meaning
just because they're maybe lost in a
world view
you're not
you're not changing your reaction or
because they're going to be stuck or
paralyzed you're changing your reaction
or you're responding in a way that's
empathetic because you believe in
empathy you're responding in a way
that's compassionate because you believe
in compassion not because
you say oh well compassion didn't work
so i'm just going to throw it throw it
all out throw my hands up imagine trying
to tell someone two plus two equals five
i don't think that's a good comparison
telling some i think you're comparing
like a mathematic equation to like
things that fundamentally involve human
beings and which which goes beyond the
abstraction i'm not talking about the
equation i'm talking about the reaction
people would have to being told
something that they hold is
fundamentally true and you're
contradicting it okay fair enough so i
think if you look at a person like daryl
davis the guy who successfully got
dozens of members of the kkk to leave
the kkk right by going to their rallies
and being literally in community with
him
his approach was not simply to go up to
them and say let me tell you why you're
wrong right his approach was to
genuinely deeply listen to them and to
hold space for them for the purpose of
holding space for them not for this is
this is tricky not for the purpose of
convincing convincing them that they
were wrong they just so happened to be
convinced that they were wrong by the
mere presence continuous presence but
but he wasn't simply spewing faxes and
he was choosing to be in community with
him and that's not a surrea or a purely
cerebral fact-based approach you are
correct that's true yeah yeah well we we
i did an event uh with some friends we
had daryl davis speak and you're
absolutely correct on that um there were
instances where he did challenge them
though because being their friend he
would right you could challenge them you
know
at a certain point the challenge is no
longer a threat to your identity that's
but i think you have to pave that road
first i think you're absolutely right i
think we should
just try to have more friends who we
disagree with and just invite him into
our spaces it is difficult it's
extremely difficult but again this is
the key
this is the hard part
not inviting them in order to persuade
them to change their mind no just invite
people to be friends to just in the
spirit of fellowship
yeah
you know the challenges though um
i think when you look at someone like
daryl davis there's there's a there's a
certain kind of like realization about
who those people were who are nasty and
racist because not all of them were
converted a lot of them were converted
and the people were converted were the
people who weren't necessarily true
believers but they were in a community
and they just helped things to be true
because that's all they ever heard
many of the guys that daryl davis met
with never even met a black person
before sure and so when they're like oh
i know about this but they weren't
like evil yeah so they were like by all
means you can i believe in freedom and
you can talk and say what you want but i
hold these views and then they realize a
lot of those things weren't true just by
talking to him
one of the challenges is there's an extr
when it comes to like the wokeness and
the culture war
you can't even get through to these
people let me tell you something when we
we did this event in uh it was in it was
in i can't remember the name of the town
so i lived in i used to live in south
jersey okay and we there was this little
theater
just it's about an hour outside of
philadelphia
at the very last minute
self-proclaimed anti-fascists threatened
to burn the theater down
because we were holding an event called
ending was ending racism violence and
authoritarianism we had an array of
speakers libertarians conservative we
had no identitarian speakers i mean
either left actually no we had some
progressive you know crt
activists we invited them but we didn't
invite any right or white identitarian
types okay
daryl davis was the
headline speaker because they're huge
fans yeah it's an amazing story and they
threatened to bring the the theater down
within a we had booked the thing almost
a year in advance
the uh the manager was like don't worry
we've had ann coulter here before we can
deal with protest
he couldn't deal with the violence
so he terminated our contract and said
we will we will not welcome you and if
you come you will we'll call the police
to have you arrested and so he was like
sue me and there's nothing we can really
do yeah we moved the main event to a
casino okay on the other side of the
river which cut our capacity in half and
did cause us financial damage people
weren't able to buy tickets yeah but we
had the event we had daryl davis
however a very brave uh uh couple
or i'm sorry sorry they divorced a very
brave men and woman who uh had a bar
across the street refused to cancel the
after party in the face of threats and
of violence and protest and we told them
like we are here for you we got your
back we you know don't worry we will
take care of you no matter what happens
like we're in this together and they
said we're having the after party no
one's going to bully us we know who you
are we know who daryl davis is we're
we're proud we agree and this is insane
antifa
and see our like you know woke activists
black lives matter showed up
and daryl davis
this is the craziest thing
um a black man who walked into clan
rallies
shook the hands with white supremacists
and converted them
walked across the street to antifa and
they all started screaming nazi at him
and he they wouldn't let him speak
he ended up posting on facebook a very
viral post where he said i am shocked in
all of my efforts meeting with white
supremacists as a black man they have at
least given me the chance to speak to
have the conversation to become friends
but by simply walking across the street
they won't even let them talk at all
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you